يا ناير بدا ساخنا اوكرانيا ربما دفئوا
الشتاء غير المتوقع هو السبب حمل العام
الجديد استمراريه للاستراتيجيه الروسيه
تدمير البنيه التحتيه ديني بروبيسكي في
كييف هاركي في الشمال الشرقي وزفرجي
وجنوبا والحراره ترتفع اكثر في الشرق
استعراضوا القوه المتبادل من جهه التضليل
من جهه اخرى يطفي يعني نكهه خاصه على
المعارك وتحديدا في سوليدار البلده
الاستراتيجيه السيطره عليها من عدمها باتت
معركه ابي حديداتها لكن لكل الاحوال تبدو
مساله وقت باسرار موسكو والتي اكدت بعد
ايام من دعوتها عدم التسرع باعلان النصر
اكاد استكمال السيطره على البلده وانا
المرحله التاليه هي بلده سوري
خلال الايام الاربعه الماضيه فقط تجاوزت
خسائر القوات الاوكرانيه في سوليدار 700
جندي والحصيله لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
فبالتالي ينفها الاوكرانيون كما ينبون
سيطره الروس على المدينه بل ويؤكدون ان
البلدات تحت سيطره قوات كياب اصلا رغم
اعترافته السابقه بصعوبه الاوضاع فيها حتى
انهم واثقون من النصر وهكذا تقول الدفاع
الاوكرانيه امازيغنسكي فاعتبر ما تروجه
روسيا حول سوليدار
فرس الان تحاول الدوله الارهابيه ومروجوها
التظاهر بان جزءا من مدينه نصر دار الذي
دمره المحتلون بالكامل تقريبا هو نوع من
الانجازات التي حققتها روسيا سيقدمون وهم
يقدمون بالفعل هذا لمجتمعهم من اجل دعم
تعبئه واعطاء الامل لاولئك الذين يؤيدون
العدوان لكن القتال مستمر
[موسيقى]
هذا التقدم الروسي تعزامنا مع قرار اخر
مهمه تعيين قائد جديد للعمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا
الجنرالري اجريزموف رئيسا للاركان حلا
السرقه الذي تولى هذه المهمه قبل ثلاثه
اشهر فقط شبكه
القليل والقصيره لاسلوبكين في المنصب قد
تكون الاجابه في خيبه الامل فخلال الاشهر
الثلاثه تباطئت الانتكاسات الروسيه لكنها
لم تتوقع جدد اسلوبكين الهيكل العسكري في
اوكرانيا وامره لبناء خطوط دفاعيه لابطاء
التقدم فانيليا انصحب بشكل منظم من مدينه
خرسون الجنوبيه والمناطق المحيطه بها غربي
نهر
الاهداف التي وضعت له وبمعنى اخر بحسب
نيويورك تايم حتى انه يتمتع به سمعه جيدا
داخل الجيش الروسي لدرجه انه مؤسس بادمان
يبغيني بروجين يسانده وهو المعارض بقرارات
الجيش قال ذات مره على تلجرام
الصادق ولديه مبادئ ويثق به الجيش لمن
يمكن مقارنه رغم هذه التصريحات لكن بحسب
واشنطن بوست هناك سببان رئيسيان
لاستبداليه
تقدم في محمود والاهم ضربه اوكرانيا على
مكان
[موسيقى]